social media is buzzing about eating for
longevity thanks to the new Netflix show
about Blue Zone so what are the diet
secrets of communities that live to a
100 years young well let's bust out that
Veno baby cuz we're going to find out
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today I'm going to be eating a
blue zone of improv diet and discussing
how specific dietary patterns may help
you live into the triple digits but
before we get started don't forget to
subscribe and also check out my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook in the
description below for some balanced meal
inspiration I can't promise that you'll
make it to 100 with these recipes but
it's definitely an evidence-based chance
so super quickly here blue zones is a
term coined by Dan Butner to capture the
specific geographical areas in the world
with the most centenarians AKA the
greatest concentration of people who are
living past 100 so the five blue zones
include okanawa in Japan NOA in Costa
Rica accaria in Greece Sardinia in Italy
and lomalinda in California and despite
being situated literally all around the
globe there were nine major similarities
or pillars in these communities as it
pertains to movement outlook on life
diet and connection I'm going to explain
these with some examples as we go along
but let's hop until breakfast because
your girl is hungry so according to
Dan's research a really Common Thread
amongst a lot of the blue zones is the
frequent consumption of coffee
especially as a social experience with
family and friends love this journey for
us because as you guys know I need my
coffee and apparently in aaria Greece
they boil their coffee grounds instead
of filtering them which is said to just
kind of like increase the beneficial
antioxidants which are associated with a
reduced risk of chronic disease
interesting as for breakfast we are
going to NOA Costa Rica for something
called Gallop Pinto so basically we got
some black beans we got some rice salsa
all cooked together and then you can add
in whatever veggies you've got I've got
some bell peppers and some frozen squash
and then sometimes it's served with eggs
which I'm going to do to add a little
bit of protein in there but sounds super
simple and delish so in the show Dan
talks a lot about the importance of
beans and legumes across blue zones
especially in in Costa Rica the
Mediterranean and in the vegetarian
community of lomalinda California and
this totally makes sense as one that he
found that people lived in extra eight
years for every ounce of legumes that
they ate it also makes sense because
we've all learned from a very young age
that beans beans are good for the heart
and I don't know I will take a little
bit of farting for good heart
health plus a huge bonus in this economy
when animal costs are literally through
the roof okay so this was insanely easy
to make Brody you get one I get one cuz
in the blue zones it's all about
Community it's all about sharing so grab
that grab that let's take a little
taster it is hot as
hell it's actually pretty good very easy
to drink I I didn't even put anything in
it it's got like a nice smooth taste to
it I love that bib up because I this is
the wrong outfit for this meal I made
him extra sloppy for me I know how you
skid like them
sloppy that is so good the rice I
wouldn't have thought i' do the rice but
the rice I'm here
for it's good you know normally whenever
I eat breakfast or lunch I'm like
sitting here scrolling through Tik Tok
or reading comments or answering emails
on my phone Etc but today we're living
like the Blue Zone and that means really
making an effort to slow down live
presently in the moment and making major
efforts to reduce stress and I don't
know reading vicious troll comments as I
try to have a basic meal isn't exactly
relaxing nor is excessive social media
use generally good for public health so
bye-bye loging off it's going to be a
lonely meal but I think I'm going to
enjoy it m m m
coffee first now family is also a huge
part of the blue zones there's a lot of
generational housing going on and taking
care of one's Elders is really built
into the culture so like they don't put
granny in a nursing home when they can
have her move in with the rest of the
gang get me out of here I'm not sure I'm
ready for that but I can give Grandma
sharp a call I guess I got to turn on my
phone for this
Grandma where are you hi Ma happy
birthday yeah you want to come by like
oneish we got a hole we got a hole in a
stuffy we need to deal with major
emergency yep yep okay love you bye it
is officially soup season and despite
living in yearr round gorgeous Sunshine
the sardinians Apparently love their
Minon soup and I love that because it is
a built-in hunger crushing combo with
the beans that we discussed and lots of
fiber and antioxidant Rich veg and
honestly one of my favorite meditative
activities is to make soup so one of the
tenants of the blue zones is to live
with purpose whether that's investing in
faith spirituality advocacy work or
passion and cooking has really always
been a passion of mine and it's one that
I rarely get to exercise now that I have
kids so making slow food like soup to me
can be a really meditative ative
experience now another thing that Dan
points out is that folks in the blue
zones are not low carb they eat carbs
they love life especially the Italians
they do however focus on higher fiber or
fermented carbohydrates more often so
things like sweet potatoes in the okaga
uh whole grains in lomalinda and
sourdough Breads in Sardinia and again
this makes sense yuck because the
research suggests that folks who eat the
most fiber reduce the risk of dying by
23% compared to those who eat the least
now I feel like a whole grain bread
would be slightly higher in fiber to
pair with a little soup action but I am
personally obsessed with sourdough and
it's uniquely beneficial because the
fermentation increases the
bioavailability of the nutrients it also
lowers the gluten and the bread's
glycemic index while feeding the good
bacteria which is also associated with
longevity okay so I know you guys were
cring ining with how full I just packed
that pot but I pulled it off guys and I
used up all the left of reng in my
fridge so that is a very big win in my
books another big win is how
ridiculously delicious and nutritious
this
looks that is so good oh that flavor
just like it's been cooking all day long
a little dunk I'm not scared of
s I'm crying cuz it's good but also cuz
I definitely burnt the roof of my mouth
worth it all right it is cool but it's
not raining outside which is a huge
bonus for a fall here in Canada so I
feel like this calls for some joyful
movement and this is really Central to
the experience of communities in
different blue zones so movement is
intuitively and naturally built into
their day often from doing like
functional activities like gardening or
dancing in the evenings or just like
walking up and down steep streets from
the markets now I'm lucky to live in a
somewhat walkable City so I do try to
walk whenever possible and I do know
that safe spaces for exercise are a
privilege so obviously please just do
your best with where you live poppy
Poppy's my guard dog here she's not very
good at it probably if we were to get
into trouble I would be the one rescuing
her but the girl needs to walk so let's
move our bodies come on pops okay let's
get started on dinner here in inspired
by okanawa Japan so in the show they
reveal that purple sweet potatoes make
up about
67% of the okanawa diet talk about not
keto now purple sweet potatoes
apparently have about twice the
antioxidants as you know regular sweet
potatoes thanks to the bright colorful
anthocyanin compounds so I looked far
and wide for a purple sweet potato I
literally called 20 different grocery
stores apparently they're not easy to
find here in Canada so I did have to
just settle for the regular old yam
actually this is a sweet potato just a
regular one but anyway that's going to
be my base and then on top I'm going to
do some kind of like stir fry situation
with tofu and some veg in there plus
some miso soup on the side minimally
processed plant-based proteins like tofu
are really popular in the blue zones
where generally meat consumption is
quite low and again this totally makes
sense soy products are rich in
antioxidants called isoflavones which
help to reduce the risk of heart disease
and even some cancers like breast
endometrial colon stomach and prostate
cancer and fermented soy which is
something that youd find something like
miso is associated with greater lifespan
this looks and smells amazing and really
could not be simpler to pull off super
inexpensive super great for just using
up whatever little leftovers and goodies
you've
got that is good another concept that is
Central to the okan food philosophy is
is something called harachi boom which
not only sounds super adorable but
essentially it means to eat until about
80% full in Dan's words it allows us to
feel satiated without stuffed now when
we think about our hunger and soti cues
I do think that for a lot of people it
can be helpful to use the hunger
fullness scale and harachi Buu is
probably not going to feel the same to
everyone and I also don't think that we
need to make a hard and fast rule of
like 80% but the idea here is to listen
to your body and until content rather
than letting yourself get to the point
of feeling stuffed and
uncomfortable oh how have I not made
miso soup from a packet before this is
so
good all right lovely last but not least
my favorite course dessert and we are
living our best lives here because that
is what we do in the blue zones so that
means a little Veno and I picked myself
up these little Greek honey donuts
called lum lumu luku mes lukumades
lukumades please don't please don't kill
me guys I I'm not Greek and that is hard
to say lumu lumu lumu cadis lumads
Google embarrassing let's let's listen
lumu CAD pronounce it l oh ladis ladis
lukumades how do you say it lukumades
okay lukumades I got that and they look
delicious they're basically like little
honey soaked Donuts I mean how can you
go wrong with that and I got me some red
wine what am I doing oh Abby this is so
embarrassing I didn't even I didn't even
take the the amate move I didn't even
take the the wrapper
off put it right I wasn't paying
attention I was just talking yeah we
will fix this guys we will fix this
problem I haven't even had anything to
drink yet this is a problem all right
let's screw in
again that's what she
says anyways back to honey so honey is
actually huge in the blue zones because
it's rich in antioxidants and it's been
associated with lower blood pressure and
heart health ditto with the wine um
moderate wine consumption is also a very
common fixture in a lot of blue zones
again likely because of its antioxidants
levels which basically LED itself to
this j-shaped curve we see with alcohol
consumption benefits and risk so there's
like a sweet spot of about 100 gram of
alcohol per week or about six glasses of
wine per week where we see the lowest
risk of heart disease or death folks who
completely abstain have slightly higher
risk and those who drink a lot more have
significantly higher risks I personally
don't Advocate trying to get your
antioxidants from wine but what I do
think maybe really important and maybe
playing into this longevity enhancing
role here is that with with that glass
of wine often comes human connection and
socializing so one teaching that I find
is quite consistent across blue zones is
a recognition that social connection is
really important for our health in the
okanawa they call moay having a group of
five friends in LMA Linda they've got a
very strong faith-based community and
they've got like shared choir practice
and in Sardinia they live with multiple
Generations Under One Roof now research
consistently shows that social
relationships and Community actually
extend our life so I say eat your
dessert laugh with your friends and
family and enjoy life and on that note
Brody I know it's a Tuesday night but I
feel like we deserve this little dut
action look how cute these little things
are that is
good oh this is a good pairing and I
didn't even know it m honey and red wine
they best friends and that my friends
takes us to the end of the day and I
don't know if the wine is talking but
honestly I feel great obviously
longevity is a very complicated topic
and I had a lot of fun testing out some
staple meals and habits from the blue
zones we have covered a lot of points
throughout the day but I want to quickly
recap on the nine pillars of the Blue
Zone lifestyle that likely contribute to
their long vibrant lives joyful movement
living with purpose stress reduction
mindful eating focusing on Plants
moderate wine consumption belonging to a
community putting Family First and
investing in social networks all I know
is that Toronto is in no way conducive
to most of these pillars so I might need
to start learning like Italian or Greek
but on that note that is all that I have
for you guys today if you are from a
blue zone or who have visited one I
would love to hear your thoughts and EXP
experiences in the comments be sure to
subscribe and I will see you next time
on Abby's kitchen
bye